19 novels flies
mister president laughter few members
of the court
appointed as members of the european
commission the european council to the
vote of approval in the
european parliament
i solemnly commit myself to the
treaties and the charter of
fundamental rights of the european union  carry out
all my
duties exercise my responsibilities with
complete independence in
the general interest of the Union
in the performance of my duties not
seek
or take instructions from any government agency body or agency refrain from
any action  is incompatible
with the character of my hand or the
performance of my duties
I take note of the obligation introduced by
the Treaty on the Functioning of
the European
Union that each Member State
must respect this character and not attempt
to  to influence the committee in the performance
of their duties
furthermore I commit  commits me, during
and after my term of office, to
the obligations arising from my
duties,
in particular to exercise fairness and
discretion in
accepting certain positions or benefits
after my term of office
[Applause]
thank you